so it's my pleasure
to open this university lecturer and
then to turn this over to provost Alan
Brinkley let me just say two things very
quickly I whatever you do in life there
are always a few people who just define
in their person and in their behavior
the thing that you do the sort of line
of work that you're in an IRA I have
always felt I think everybody in this
room feels is someone who makes you feel
proud to be a professor to be a scholar
to be a teacher he in his very being
makes that seem possible and the ideal
towards which we all live and strive
part of that is that almost everything
that IRA talks about whether it's small
or big is interesting it's always
enjoyable there's always a sense of
humor there's always something that you
can take away from it and the IRA today
we'll be talking about something big and
that's our great pleasure the other
thing I just want to say is that the
role of the provost includes trying to
select them selecting the people who
will give this lecture and what I just
said about IRA is also true about Alan
Brinkley and this will be the last
university lecture that Alan will
participate in and that he will
introduce the lecturer and so I'd like
to recognize Alan Brinkley for her
services provost
and it's now my pleasure to turn this
over to Al well it's really a very
special pleasure for me to introduce I
Arquette's Nelson as tonight's universe
university lecture and for many reasons
some of them are personal together IRA
and I have run a workshop for more than
a decade which brings together faculty
and graduate students from history and
political science and other disciplines
and effort that has flourished for the
last 13 years and working with IRA on
this has been one of the great pleasures
of my life at Columbia when I was
appointed Provost six years ago and
realized that the search for a new vice
president for arts and sciences would
continue into a second year Lee and I
asked him to step in as interim vice
president a job he handled with amazing
skill and vision and in which he was an
enormous help to me we share an interest
in the 1930s IRA help me with my book on
the new deal and I recently had the
pleasure of reading parts of his
forthcoming book that also focuses in
part on the New Deal and for many years
we were neighbors in the building in
which we lived before moving up to
Morningside Heights but IRA is of course
more than a great friend and a great
citizen of Columbia he's also a great
scholar his appointment is jointly in
political science and history and I know
a few people who bridged these two
disciplines as fully or as well he has
been the president of the American
Political Science Association the
president of the social science history
association the chairman of the board of
the Russell Sage Foundation a member of
the academy of arts and sciences and i
could go on and on but these are just
reflections of his real achievement of
body of scholarship of extraordinary
range and importance indeed of such
range
and importance that it's almost
impossible to characterize IRA has
written about cities about the academic
disciplines in the university about
class about liberalism and Marxism about
war and trade and especially about race
a subject that he is addressed with
unusual clear-sightedness and rigor most
recently in his exceptional book when
affirmative action was white published
in 2005 and I'd like to read just a
short passage from this beginning of
this book which I think exemplifies both
the hard-headed realism and the moral
power with which IRA examines even the
most admired moments in history he
writes of Lyndon Johnson's famous and
greatly admired speech to fulfill these
rights at Howard University in 1965 in
which Johnson first proposed affirmative
action and Ira rights this was no
ordinary leader and to fill fulfill
these rights was no run-of-the-mill
speech was rightly recalled as the first
moment when a president from any region
forcefully invisibly sponsored
affirmative action for blacks but IRA
did not stop there looking back over the
troubled and fragile history of firm
ative action since nineteen sixty-five
he wrote the speech also should be
remembered for how it highlighted a
powerful historical question did not
adequately answer excuse me why did the
disparity between white and black
Americans widen after the Second World
War despite the country's prosperity the
answers Lyndon Johnson offered were less
compelling than his discussion about
what to do once legal segregation had
ended in voting rights had been secured
the missing words that balmy evening in
1965 might well have attended to the
history of affirmative action for whites
had the president done so his inspiring
but rather open-ended conclusions might
have placed affirmative action for
blacks on the differ
and arguably more secure foundation it's
with great pleasure that I introduce our
Katznelson to give alleged lecture
entitled what is toleration reflection
on Jews civic membership and the Western
liberal tradition IRA
thank you so very much Lee and Alan
thanks for your generous words your
fictional statements yeah and for so
graciously leading this great University
um Lee took words out of my mouth as I
too want to acknowledge the special
service alan has given this community is
our chief academic officer for the past
six years it's been special for the
university to have someone of his
scholarly commitments and capacities at
its helm so thank you
I first stepped into this building as an
applicant to columbia college when what
is now the visitor center just over
there served as headquarters for the
office of admissions eight months later
some 600 young men all imagine this all
wearing light blue caps the required
freshman beanie crowded into this Great
Hall as the incoming class of nineteen
sixty-six we were greeted by the Dean of
Columbia College David Truman one of the
country's leading political scientists I
vividly recall his sober speech that
previewed the extraordinary late 17th
century texts by John Locke on
representative government and toleration
that we assume would read in our
required class on contemporary
civilization but that was not his main
purpose with references to the Soviet
gulag and Nazi atrocities he wanted to
exhort each of us to feel responsible
for the fate of the Western liberal
tradition a political culture that
offered rights to individuals protection
from predatory regimes government based
on consent and the rule of law in
classrooms and tutorials and at public
occasions I soon was privileged to hear
for its turn and Sydney Morgan Besser
one Linds and Richard Hofstadter William
looked in burg and Robert Merton Daniel
Bell and Lionel trilling also refused to
take Western liberalism for granted in
what Huff's that are called the complex
and terrifying world these scholars
insisted that to advance and protect
this tradition we should identify its
weaknesses assess its uneven qualities
and reveal its unbalanced application
that is we should practice what
Professor trilling designated as
emancipating liberalism from its naivete
in their hands critical history and
social science performed the act
trilling identity
fight as unmasking a rejection and I
quote of settled institutionalized
conceptions of reality and how it works
and the discovery of principles of
causation that do the work of unmasking
my lecture this evening is a modest act
of unmasking it's motivated by a wish to
repay the enormous debt that I indeed we
all owe to that generation of post-war
scholars and intellectuals who
understood that a simple reassertion of
liberal modernism had become radically
insufficient my subject is toleration
more specifically the relationship
between toleration and the Western
liberal tradition my strategy is to
think about this relationship in tandem
with the long history of Jews in England
a history that began in 10 96 when Jews
who had been living in Rouen in Normandy
fled across the channel to seek refuge
from an to seek refuge from a Norman
King in England after they had been
assaulted at the start of the First
Crusade toleration the philosopher and
economist Friedrich Hayek declared two
decades ago is of course an essential
and inseparable part of the great
tradition of liberalism my talk
considers the of course in high x
assertive declaration many scholars
share his view that toleration is a
primary liberal value quote toleration
is the substantive heart of liberalism
the political philosopher of the late
gene Hampton argued Ingrid crepelle
Russell Hardin and Stephen macedo
important students of the subject open a
recent essay with a declarative claim
that quote toleration stands as a value
at the core of the liberal democratic
political tradition in this presentation
I discuss this seemingly settled matter
by transform
haix confident affirmation a claim I
consider to be far too certain and to
assured into three different questions
the first is normative should toleration
be an essential and inseparable part of
the great tradition of liberalism
because toleration is grudging fragile
and controversial much is at stake in
how we answer that question I argue that
we cannot do without toleration and that
liberalism provides toleration with its
most sheltered but not entirely secure
foundation the second question is
historical when did toleration gain at
least the appearance of the status Hayek
announced I utilize the eviction of the
Jews in 1290 and disputes about their
standing as residents and citizens after
their readmission in 1655 as a way to
answer this question and show what
happens when liberalism and toleration
either are not joined at all or are
joined only very uncertainly in
considering key episodes in Anglo Jewish
history subject about which I am no
specialist we can observe the ultimate
emergence of liberal toleration as a
valuable outcome but we also can see
that toleration is not a first order
inseparable and essential liberal value
toleration rather emerged as a
contingent result shaped under pressure
over time a very long time by patchworks
of fighting and compromise that
ultimately enlarged liberalism's
conceptual space and institutional
boundaries the third question is
empirical what accounts for the slow
contingent not entirely secure but
significant affiliation of toleration
with liberalism and liberalism with
toleration
how have features of liberalism and
toleration actually interacted once this
status has been achieved this evening I
primarily discuss the normative and
historical questions interspersing brief
thoughts about how empirical studies of
toleration might best move ahead
toleration addresses some of the most
difficult and persistent features of
human social relations when hatred
combines with hierarchy individuals and
groups are exposed to xela tree and
danger toleration is an act of bearing
and allowing it is a choice of not doing
despite the ability to act a condition
of toleration is the existence of
persons with ways of thinking and
behaving that elicit more than mild
discomfort but scales of antipathy as
such a target Jews of course have been
the group exposed to xela tree and
danger for the longest period within the
Christian West toleration is grudging
the central problem of toleration as
susan mendez puts the point is
explaining how it can be right to permit
what is wrong such forbearance entails a
self conscious decision to endure that
which is deeply disliked to tolerate
something or someone Stephen Luke's thus
notes is to abstain from acting against
what one finds unacceptable unlike
tolerance which need not be
self-conscious and is a descriptive term
for comparatively sociable patterns of
human relationships toleration is more
than just not doing toleration is
reflective not doing authorities who
possess means of repression and
exclusion decide for various reasons to
bind themselves by convention or by law
toleration is fragile a precious but
easily broken human achievement it is
what our colleague George Fletcher call
sells an unstable virtue it rarely is
anyone's first choice for some it is too
permissive a silencing of belief an
abdication of judgment and unhappy
compromise with ways of life that might
contradict or even threaten society's
most cherished standards and ideals this
is a view articulated by the moral and
political philosopher Alicia kolakowski
who worries that toleration forces a
suspension of judgment even more common
today is the claim that toleration is an
inadequate ideal in societies which
value in which deep moral diversity
sorry has become an established way of
life that toleration endorses a
hierarchy of cultures toleration in this
view can function as a partner of
domination toleration in short is
controversial from these perspectives
toleration either asks too much or
delivers too little it would be glib to
simply dismiss these objections but in
my view it is precisely the location of
toleration within the field of tension
demarcated by these competing critics
that produces it's indispensable
capacity to search for what is
reasonable in situations of deep
cultural moral and religious differences
that generate a version and where power
is uneven that is in circumstances that
constitute the world in which we live
most of the time however flawed and
inadequate decent human life cannot do
without toleration a world without
toleration as a stark world of unbridled
conflict and coercion it is a world of
winners and losers for whom costs can be
very high even ultimate toleration
becomes necessary the philosopher
Bernard Williams observed quote when
different groups moral
political religious realize there is no
alternative to living together that is
to say no alternative except armed
conflict which will not resolve their
disagreements and will impose continuous
suffering as an alternative to suffering
and violence toleration is most needed
in circumstances that make respect
cooperation and social peace difficult
to obtain quote we need to tolerate
other people and their ways of life
Williams ruefully noted only in
situations that make it very difficult
to do so toleration thus is motivated
and should be judged by its capacity to
manage deeply felt commitments in
inconvenient conditions as a formula to
manage circumstances marked by aversion
passion and danger toleration combines
features that allow minorities to
reproduce their own distinct identity
with varying degrees of particularity
toleration permits their physical
presence abiding those who are disliked
to share a geographic area with those
who find them objectionable toleration
supplies policing to provide members of
the minority with physical security
protecting them from public or private
violence toleration makes it possible
for the group to sustain material life
offering access to means of earning by
contrast dislike groups whose members do
not experience toleration may not be
admitted or if present risk being
extruded they often live on a plateau of
anxiety fearful for their persons and
frequently are subjected to economic
restrictions limited to particular
occupational niches and subordinate role
the not tolerated are especially
vulnerable to hierarchies of humiliation
toleration becomes stronger and more
assertive when it is embedded with
in liberalism in no age a historian of
early 17th century ideas has written is
the idea of toleration of conception
which can subsist as an end in itself
unconnected to liberalism toleration
risks being entirely instrumental
whether for religious or secular reasons
unconnected to liberalism toleration
also is wholly subject to the whims of
political and religious authorities
liberal values and institutions by
contrast can offer sanctuary to
toleration and make it more likely to
endure liberal views about the
autonomous person equal citizenship and
the impartiality of the state can
provide otherwise missing justifications
for toleration resistance to pressure
and force by helping to show why other
people's beliefs and conduct even if
grievously mistaken should be protected
and placed beyond the reach of public
sanction without liberalism that is
without an affiliation with individual
rights and civic membership toleration
essential features of admission
protection and earning grow more
provisional and structurally uncertain
they cannot be counted on without a bond
between liberalism and toleration
minorities lack reasonable means to
assess life's probabilities in such
circumstances it becomes difficult to
maintain a comfortable zone within which
to create and recreate cultural identity
or sustain what took veal called bonds
of memory although the liberal tradition
provides toleration with its strongest
available foundation central liberal
designs regarding rights representation
and opinion nonetheless can come to be
at odds with toleration we cannot
imagine toleration sorry we cannot
imagine liberalism without the
individual rights Ronald Dworkin
designates as the trump cards of
political life rights that cannot be
taken away liberalism is impossible
without mechanisms of political
representation that transmit what
citizens believe and desire into the
domain of the state and that adjudicate
among them in a legislature whose
members simultaneously represent
particular and general interests quote
the first and fundamental positive law
of all Commonwealth's lock announced in
the second treatise is the establishing
of the legislative power this
legislative is not only the supreme
power of the Commonwealth but sacred and
unalterable end quote liberalism also
requires that decisions taken about
public affairs be adjudicated within a
climate of public discussion debate and
deliberation in the press in civil
society in associations that galvanized
interest and involvement in political
parties that organized political
participation and order policy choices
into bundles of alternatives each of
these features that are central to the
liberal tradition raises difficult
questions that affect disliked persons
and their prospects for toleration
questions of physical presence personal
security economic access and group
identity are bound up with rights
representation and debate who gets to
live where liberal rights exist how are
those persons made secure on what terms
can they enter the economy how much
adjustment are they asked to make to
their cultural commitments in order to
gain entry security and life's
provisions most important when disliked
persons are admitted to a country's
territory what is their civic standing
are they rights bearing persons what
criteria should distinguish those who
are given leave to enter inside
from those who were kept outside in
political systems where civil society
preferences are transported into the
state by way of legislative
representation what happens when civil
society transmits ugly restrictive
exclusionary preferences how should
legislatures represent such beliefs and
values how does the open character and
scope of public speech and press
campaigning transmit and deepen
intolerance these are urgent research
questions about which we still know far
too little the history of toleration in
England usually is assessed at the
intersection of two issues central to
the complex history of Christianity the
variegated and often contested relations
of state and church and the scope
provided for organizational and
theological pluralism the country's
relatively small Jewish communities
understandably are ordinarily dealt with
at the periphery of those main narrative
strands this is a missed opportunity
Anglo Jewish history helps us think
about the relationship of toleration to
liberalism the Jewish experience is
revealing not least because unattractive
as well as appealing features of their
encounters with English politics and
society have been affected significantly
by how liberal rights and arrangements
notably Parliament have mapped rules for
social and political membership have
drawn up boundaries for exclusion and
inclusion and have shaped possibilities
for decent coexistence the episodic
course of Jewish life in England offers
a standpoint from which to observe
toleration changing meanings in a
country where liberal ideas and
institutions were incubated and advanced
but also where sectarian enmity and
violence hard confessional commitments
uncompromising pressures for conformity
calls for persecution and civil
intervention on back
of truth and uniformity and conjoined
efforts by political and ecclesiastical
authorities to contain and discipline
religious dissidents were persistent and
ideologically official facts of life at
issue is whether and how the development
of liberal rights representation and
opinion modified the country's vectors
of intolerance shifted the climates of
opinion enlarged resources of
forbearance changed the content and
parameters of Orthodoxy and altered
institutional practices under conditions
where the circumstances of religious and
civil power were deeply uncertain i
start in 1290 the year edward the first
expel his kingdoms small Jewish
community Edward some of you will know
is revered as a great lawmaker the first
consolidator of political representation
by recognizably modern parliaments in
this way he helps secure a political
system based on rights by members of
civil society a revolutionary
development first announced in magna
carta the great charter issued under
pressure by King John in 1215 the period
that preceded Jewish expulsion did not
lack for toleration and did not lack for
liberalism but the two were utterly
disconnected with liberalism
unconstrained by toleration political
representation we will see played a key
causal role in fashioning Western
Christian domes first mass eviction I
turned second to seventeen fifty three
ninety eight years after Oliver Cromwell
permitted Jews to return to England
parliament passed but quickly rescinded
an act for the naturalization of Jew
that legislation specified and I quote
that person's professing the Jewish
religion may upon application for that
purpose be naturalized by Parliament
without receiving the sacrament of the
Lord's Supper end quote this legislative
history reveals tensions about rights
representation and free expression of
opinion that make liberalism and
toleration uncertain partners last we
traveled to 1858 when after decades of
debate a confessing Jew was permitted to
join the House of Commons some seven
decades after the French Revolution had
removed political disabilities from Jews
who did not convert to Christianity and
slightly more than a decade before
Germany did the same England extended
toleration for Jews to include Civic
membership I reflect on the terms of
that debate and decision on the status
of the outcome and on the inescapable
tensions that remain whenever liberalism
and toleration are joined toleration was
first fashioned as a self-conscious
doctrine of forbearance within the
medieval church to deal with Christian
heresy and to manage ties with
non-christians especially Jews about
whom the church was deeply ambivalent
Jews of course were not insiders capable
of heresy but they also were not
outsiders in the usual sense for they
were embedded inside the grand narrative
of Christianity should they be
considered elder brothers whose company
testified to the truth of the Gospels or
as stubborn and primitive persons whose
example of resistance to the truth
threatens the reach and legitimacy of
the Gospels how should the boundary
between us and them be managed one
answer though by no means the only
answer was toleration it was advanced as
a form of self-restraint a moral triumph
of truth
showing charity to error the two primary
compilations of canon law the decretum
graziani of 11 40 and the 1234 decree
dolls of pope gregory the 9th a skilled
lawyer contain several statements on
circumstances under which evil practices
may be left unpunished as east van
veggie a historian of the concept has
observed taught and i quote toleration
was cheaply develop chiefly developed as
an answer to how ecclesiastical
authorities should deal with the
practices of the Jewish religion Jewish
rites were considered an evil that had
to be tolerated the major evil that was
thus prevented was the forced conversion
of the Jews for conversion to
Christianity had to be a matter of free
will moreover the Jews would be more
willing to embrace the Christian faith
the cannabis argued when they were
treated with benevolence the church
bezzie goes on to say should not only
leave the rights unpunished but should
also prevent others from disturbing them
in quote toleration of this kind was
endorsed with in medieval scholasticism
st. Thomas Aquinas as a leading example
made a case for toleration of Jews in
Samoa theologica and in a brief treatise
on governing Jews he wrote for the
duchess of brabant notwithstanding his
elaboration of Augustine's catholic
theory of persecution though he
designated jews as quote enemies as
outsiders faded to live in perpetual sin
because of their role in the crucifixion
their rights he argued should be
tolerated as harbingers of Christian
belief and because Jews provided living
testimony to the lineage of Christianity
rulers thus should permit Jews to live
their lives securely within Christian
society his argument bezzie comments
shows that one does not have to like
Jews to be tolerant to the contrary one
had to dislike them to be tolerant for
it only applied to evil not as an
imperative of love but as a restraint on
one's hatred in 1290
such hatred was lifted not by the church
such restraint I correct myself such
restraint was not lifted by the church
but by the King Edward the first in the
context of a parliamentary negotiation
for changes to the fiscal basis of the
English state in medieval Europe's
initial but not last f Nick cleansing
Edward promulgated an expulsion order on
July 18 a Jewish exodus originating in
more than 80 locations began on October
twelfth and was completed as the king
ordered by the end of the month
disturbed only by minor violence the
Jews set out from England's ports for
Spain France Holland Germany the east of
Europe Sicily and North Africa by best
estimate they numbered no more than five
thousand persons in a population
variously estimated in the range of two
to three million as sources of capital
Jews had helped propel the growth of
markets towns networks of trade as
sources of revenue for the king and
state they had helped fund military
ventures that enhanced English power by
the late 12th century their taxes were
sufficiently important to be separately
collected and recorded the Jews were
tolerated by the church moreover for the
reasons specified in canon law and by
Aquinas they were tolerated by kings
because of their assets but they were
expelled by one of England's most
effective kings despite those
instrumental contributions any
persuasive answer to why Edward banished
the Jews I argue must must assess how
their circumstances were affected by
Magna Carta and Parliament what Magna
Carta established diesel wrote is the
principle that liberties are nothing
until they have become rights commenting
on this anti absolutist constitutional
document that placed Kings under the
rule of law the great jurist Rosco pound
celebrated Magna Carta as the foundation
of English and American public law for
nearly eight centuries
quote whose guarantees to the individual
man are the proudest possession of
Englishmen and their descendants
everywhere Magna Carta famously
stipulated and I quote that all these
customs and liberties that we have
granted shall be observed in our kingdom
in so far as concerns our own relations
with our subjects and quote the phrase
concerns relations with our own subjects
however manifestly did not include the
Jews who were the property of the crown
not rights bearing subjects indeed the
tenth and eleventh clauses of this great
charter of Liberty adjust debts to Jews
following the death of the debtor those
provisions signal that the status of the
Jews and their Economic Affairs was an
appropriate subject of exchanges between
the king and a right sparing civil
society from which Jews had not the
slightest chance of entering soon enough
demands for Jewish expulsion from
various places within the kingdom became
regular features of 13th century
baronial rebellions especially during
the upheavals of the late 12 50 s and 12
60s peaking in the temporarily
successful revolt led by simon de
montfort further Jewish physical
insecurities vastly increased when towns
exercised the rights offered by Magna
Carta which promised and i quote london
and all other cities boroughs towns and
courts all their liberties and free
customs and quote after Magna Carta
towns were given scope to expel their
Jews De Montfort oversaw the expulsion
of Leicester's Jews in 1231 other towns
soon took the same course of action in
the decade spanning 1234 to 1244 these
included Newcastle Warwick High Wycombe
Southampton berkhamsted Newberry spin em
land the turbulent transition to a
parliamentary kingship at mid century
further place Jews in a situation of
durable hazard the Jewish quarter of
Canterbury was burned in 1261 London's
jewelry was sacked in 12 62 in a great
massacre hundreds were killed two years
later in London deadly rioting also was
directed against the Jews in 1264 doing
month during Montfort's ascendancy in
Canterbury once again and in Worcester
Bristol Bradford Winchester Lincoln
nodding them it was as the medievalist
William Jordan remarks quote a
particularly bloody civil war for
English Jews the most enduring result of
the barons war was the second most
profound feature of liberalism the
invention of a national legislature with
representatives drawn from every Shire
and from three different stations in
life large land owning barons lesser
landholder nights and town burgesses
Edwards first Parliament met in April
1275 when responding to popular demand
it curbed Jewish money lending the
central permitted occupation for a group
that was forbidden to own land and was
excluded from urban craft guilds the
statute of jewel of jewelry that
Parliament enacted opens with the avowal
and I quote from the statute the King
though he and his ancestors have always
received great benefits from the Jewish
people in the past has nevertheless for
the honour of God and the common benefit
of the people the common benefit of the
people ordained and established that
from now on no Jew shall lend anything
at usury Jews clearly were not included
in any definition of the people for whom
the common good was sought this first
truly modern Parliament also prescribed
and I quote from the law that each Jew
after he is seven years old shall wear a
distinguishing mark on his outer garment
that is to say in the form of two tables
joined of yellow felt the length of six
inches and the breadth of three inches
and that each one after he is 12 years
old shall yearly at Easter
pay to the king whose surf he is a tax
of 3 pence and this to hold as well for
a woman as for a man and quote it was
Edward the first Rosco pound observed
who quote elaborated and completed the
organization of parliament his
legislation I'm quoting pound was so
full and well done that the laws of the
next three centuries are not much more
than an expansion of it end quote Edward
is remembered for being an immensely
capable king who pursued war-making to
unify Britain who possessed a modern
sense of international relations as a
balance of power and who strengthen the
crown by institutionalizing a new
institutional order that associated
Royal rule with parliamentary consent
inducing Parliament to legislate
effectively across a wide range
including fiscal affairs with Edwards
reign diesel observed quote the rights
for which Parliament had tended to
Constance consecrate we're forever
recognized and tolerably respected with
Edwards reign pound wrote begins the
legal order as an order guaranteeing
Liberty as it has stood in the
english-speaking world since that time
guaranteeing Liberty but for whom surely
not the Jews who were expelled by Edward
during the summer of 1290 when
Parliament gathered at Westminster on 15
July the Knights were summoned to join
the Barons to deliberate about revenue
they endorsed what today's leading
student of the subject Robert Stacey
calls the law I quote the largest single
grant of Taxation conceded by Parliament
to any medieval king it replaced less
reliable forms of traditional feudal
taxation with a more modern tax on
movable wealth the Knights who had been
most vulnerable to losing their holdings
to Jewish moneylenders Stacey argued
exact 'add expulsion as their price
quote Edward got his
and in return Parliament got the
expulsion once ejected the Jews remained
absent for nearly four centuries until
they were permitted back by Cromwell in
December 1655 that second period of
Jewish life in England was initiated by
the Amsterdam rabbi Manasa been Israel's
famous petition to Oliver Cromwell
Cromwell convened the wife whole
conference of theologians merchants and
lawyers to debate the question a massive
pamphlet war ensued a great modern
expression of free speech to influence
its five sessions held between four and
eighteen December 1655 the advocates of
readmission offered millenarian and
mercantile reasons the opponents argued
that Jewish worship constituted
blasphemy the Jews favored ritual murder
and would induce Christians to convert
that Jewish economic competition would
be unfair that Jews would overrun and
overpopulated island in one of the most
forceful anti-immigrant documents ever
written a leading league legal figure
William Prynne who led the opposition
insisted that Parliament not Cromwell
make the decision about Jewish admission
but that did not happen instead Cromwell
offered Jews the tacit consent to return
a privilege of settlement they were
tolerated to live throughout the kingdom
enjoy police protection earn a living as
a popular 19th century history of the
Jews summarized quote they obtained
Liberty to carry on their public worship
to practice all trades and professions
and hold property except such as not
permitted to aliens none of these
privileges that I continued to quote
were withdrawn or modified during the
eighteenth century on the other hand the
treatise continued the Jews were not
naturalized could not possess land could
not hold any public office of whatsoever
kind were not in any real sense English
citizens end quote this then was no
liberal toleration classified as alien
infidels the Jews neither asked for nor
had they any chance to obtain admission
into the political realm following the
model of early 18th century legislation
permitting the naturalization of alien
Protestants the government of wig Prime
Minister Henry Pelham proposed in 1753
to do the same for the Jews he and other
advocates stressed how that group
brought important assets to a growing
English economy of global reach at first
what was widely known as the Jew bill
faced little resistance but by the time
it passed in May opponents were
mobilizing anti-jewish sentiment at the
closing debate in the House of Lords
John Percival the 2nd Earl of egmont and
the father of the future prime minister
stressed quote the obstinate
superstition of the Jews arguing and I
quote the total difference of their
customs in every circumstance of life
makes it utterly impossible for them to
mix with our people even if they are
qualified for it in every other respect
and quote a pamphlet war in a press
campaign led by the London English post
erupted not just about this legislation
but questioning the very presence of
Jews in England once enacted the bill
became a leading public issue Jews were
widely represented as speculators and
plundering usurers as concerned to
gather influence and power as receivers
of stolen property as underhanded
competitors as a menacing race of
crucify errs and child killers as
desirous of converting Christians as a
danger to the integrity of the nation
generating great passion the campaign
succeeded the Act was repealed in late
November before any individual had
utilized its provisions notwithstanding
the demand of William
crin and other opponents of Jewish entry
a century earlier the Jews had been
allowed back without parliamentary
deliberation and sanction in providing
the first opportunity for public debate
in England on the status of the Jews
since their readmission the Ark of the
Jew bill indicated that Parliament was
more than a closed oligarchy or a site
for a leet trusteeship but an assembly
now responsive to intolerant views and
popular pressure as a casualty of the
permeability of the state to the
Preferences of members of civil society
a central tenet of liberal politics the
events of 1753 are at odds with high x
essential and inseparable claim about
liberalism and toleration even more this
history shows how the early spread of a
print culture and proto democratic
political participation and mass
mobilization conjoined with
parliamentary representation could
outrun toleration as an ethical legal
and institutional value in 1858 Lionel
Rothschild entered Parliament this was
an important Parliament the one in which
the government of india was transferred
from the East India Company to the crown
with Rothschilds seating a threshold of
civic membership was crossed the
capacity to hold public office without
conversion but this hardly was a smooth
or seamless passage Rothschild first had
been elected to the commons from the
city of london in 1847 but had been
unable to take his seat because of the
nature of the required christian oath
elected again in 1850 he presented
himself to take an oath but on the Old
Testament the House of Commons voted to
permit that in
ovation on 29 July the next day swearing
on that Bible Rothchild recited the
traditional oath absent the words the
true faith of a Christian stating i omit
these words as not binding on my
conscience before he could sign the
parliamentary role the House of Commons
resolve that lacking the full oath he
could not be admitted over the course of
the three decades before Rothschild took
his seat debate in Parliament in the
press and in many public forums was
intense reflecting what the literary
Chronicle in 1819 identified with regret
as quote the strong and unwarrantable
prejudice that exists against the Jews
at stake were characterizations of their
character and the meaning of civic
inclusion listen to Robert Peel in 1834
years before he became prime minister
and a year after Catholics had secured
the right to enter political office as
the House of Commons debated a bill to
extend civic membership to the Jews peel
noted quote when his Majesty's ministers
were asked for their votes in favor of
Roman Catholics it never was hinted that
those who reject Christianity might be
admitted to the legislature the
exclusion or separation of the Jews he
continued did not arise from any
incapacitating laws but it arises from
the peculiar manners and habits of those
people themselves and quote the popular
magazine John Bull objected in 1848 to
quote such hollow liberalism that would
consider a law to admit the Jew into the
legislature of a Christian country and
in 1856 to the claptrap by quote of
civil and religious liberty there are no
British Jews at argued only quote Jews
located in Great Britain for the Jew
until he ceases to be a Jew cannot
belong to any country those various
objections failed when the bill passed
in 1858 permitting a Jewish member to be
seated without a Christian oh
John Bull took some solace from the fact
that the admission of Jews to Parliament
was not a right but a provisional
decision that could in future be
reversed observing that a responsive
legislature would quote he'd public
opinion that already has declared itself
pretty strongly in opposition but the
right to enter public life did not prove
provisional this then was the first
moment in Britain when claims about the
inherent ties of liberalism and
toleration resonated beyond Christians
Jewish admission to civic life did not
come from the exercise of the personal
prerogative of the executive as it had
in the case of readmission by Cromwell
but from within the liberal polity
following massive partisan and press
campaigns like the Jew Bill of 1753 the
end of restrictions on Jewish
parliamentary participation was an
occasion for free public debate and
parliamentary decision about which
persons should have access to the status
of Rights barring citizenship I want to
conclude by asking how we might best
understand the shift from the quick
reversal of Jewish naturalization in
1753 to the admission of a Jewish member
of parliament just a century later is
the development of liberal toleration
best traced by a history of ideas
focusing on such great texts as John
Locke's letter concerning toleration
composed in Amsterdam in 1685 and
published anonymously in England four
years later and the even more remarkable
response to the challenges and dangers
of confessional pluralism within
Christendom John tollens heterodox
brilliant polemic detailing quote
reasons for naturalizing the Jews in
Great Britain and Ireland a 17-14
pamphlet that first used the phrase the
emancipation of the Jews or would it be
better to deploy currently more
fashionable instruments of historical
real
that show how changes to toleration and
it's bonding with liberalism were
matters of strategy partisanship
instrumental reason power we would do
well I believe to refuse that choice for
each to be persuasive requires the other
realist history and social science
remind us that there was nothing
automatic or teleological about how
toleration unfolded reciprocally a
free-standing and progressive history of
ideas is radically insufficient in law
and in practice toleration never was an
uncomplicated extension of freedom and
liberalism did not necessarily fashion
or link up with toleration nor did
exclusions and patterns of persecution
melt away when leading thinkers such as
locked and Toland shifted toleration
from a site for theological debate about
heresy and religious difference to
become a political and legislative
question under conditions of religious
pluralism still their texts and the vast
array of reflections and arguments that
circulated and were debated early modern
England did powerfully widen the
available intellectual and political
space for toleration without
appreciating such ideas and without
acknowledging their engagement with
broader liberal themes the relationship
between liberalism and toleration is
impossible to comprehend if there ever
was a subject where political thought
deep history and comparative political
studies promised dividends when brought
together the question of liberalism and
toleration a question that remains
deeply pressing for us today is the one
because it is a mistake to underestimate
the potential depth and danger of
conflict or take too lightly the
prospects of intolerance we need to
deploy all our tools to find an answer
to the question urgently posed by John
Rawls and I quote how is it possible
for there to exist over time a just and
stable society of free and equal
citizens who remain profoundly /
religious philosophical and moral
doctrines we also should recall his
admonition the Wars of this century what
roles wrote with their extreme violence
and increasing destructiveness
culminating in the manic evil of the
Holocaust raised in a cute way the
question whether political relations
must be governed by power and coercion
alone end quote working as social
scientists as historians and as
interested citizens we need to better
understand when and how particular
constellations of ideas situations
institutions strategies and mechanisms
of social choice operate to produce
effective liberal toleration and shape
its character and when they do not
further we should be asking not only
whether but what kind of liberal
toleration we should wish to have for
sure liberal toleration with civic
incorporation did not erase bigotry and
danger with Jews inside the state
suspicions of Jewish difference did not
recede but it took new form in England
as in other European countries Jews
increasingly came to be seen as
inhabiting not a religious or national
but a racial category savage a
vegetation using race as a marker
characterized the successful mass
campaigns that produce the aliens act of
nineteen five in England that gave
immigration officers rather unlimited
power to exclude undesirable aliens in
the language of the law primarily Jews
who were characterized as a threat to
public health Public Order and
especially to the character of England a
corruption to the stock of Englishmen
the English authenticity of Jews also
was called into question especially as
their numbers and geographic and
occupational constant
tration increased this history lingers
in a forthcoming book Anthony Julius one
of England's leading barristers portrays
Jewish sensibilities a full century and
a half after Rothschild took his seat
Julius perhaps known to you as the
lawyer who represented Princess Diana in
her divorce from Prince Charles writes
quote what remains is a residual sense
of constraint and on occasion a sense of
vulnerability anglo jewelry remains on
guard it displays certain anxieties
about status and security that are not
altogether misconceived and quote why we
might wish to know is such apprehension
not entirely misconceived but there is
and here I conclude also ample reason to
celebrate what liberal toleration
achieved when the worst moments for
modern jewelry arrived just before and
especially during the Second World War
liberal toleration advantages despite
its cognate vulnerabilities clarified
and still something of the unevenness
remains nearly eight years ago in june
2001 the current foreign minister of
great britain david miliband the second
june to hold that emblematic position
delivered his maiden speech as a new
labour party member of parliament he had
this to say over 50 years ago my
distinguished predecessor as member for
South Shields J shooter eid was home
secretary in the nineteen forty-five
government the greatest performing
government in our history one of his
hardest tasks was to make decisions on
immigration applications from millions
of refugees around Europe there were
many hard cases one application came
from a man who had spent the war here
separated from his wife and daughter who
were in occupied Belgium with his son
who studied it who study at school and
then served in
Royal Navy the man who lodged that
application was my grandfather samuel
Miliband despite long correspondence the
then home secretary felt compelled to
deny his application there could not he
wrote be exceptions for me David
Miliband concluded it is a sign of hope
for South Shields and hope for Britain
that the grandson of a man denied
residence in Britain by the then member
for South Shields can some 50 years
later represent south shields in the
house and quote this to ultimately is a
success story for liberal toleration but
certainly not one that merits anything
like Friedrich Hayek's complacent of
course thank
thank you I want first just to thank I
rough for this wonderful and provocative
lecture ah and to open the floor up to
questions we don't have a lot of time
for questions but we'll take as many as
we can hi I'm Jackie I'm getting my
masters at ciba if you don't know about
it it's our international school and
it's fabulous I'm studying a lot about
conflict resolution right now in dr.
Betts's class and I think what you've
been talking about a lot is is tall
toleration in a liberal nationalistic
environment and I think we're moving on
to a place that's postmodern post
National globalizing telecommunications
transportation borders labor rights
being blurred and changing as we grow
into a society where there is a greater
sense of togetherness despite our
differences and the commitment we've
made to the consistency of being a part
of a specific group or nation so I guess
my question to you is what do you think
the new public policy implications will
be of this more transnational world and
do you think that the new public policy
implications should be education of
acceptance instead of tolerance which
has an automatic sense of strife within
it
that is a very large question thank you
let me make two points which are perhaps
somewhat contradictory first this is not
the first moment when the movement of
peoples the movement of the intersection
of cultures the dynamic tension that
comes when people who are very different
meet each other this is a story that's
quite old especially in this hemisphere
and I would if we had I took too much
time in my remarks but if it had more
time I might have reflected on the
debates back in 16th century about the
meaning of contact between the Spanish
colonizers and the native peoples they
discovered so we've been having a
discussion about cultural conflict
synergism in some cases genocide for
centuries the since the Peace of
Westphalia and again I'm this is a kind
of two simple and answer but since the
Peace of the world has been organized
either in states or in empires or in
some other form of political rule but
increasingly in states and today there
are nearly someone may have a better
account than I something like 200 and
therefore the question of toleration
even in a globalized world even in a
more globalized world than has been true
historically remains a question of
boundaries a question of how others
crossing boundaries are received whether
they will enjoy the three essentials of
any kind of toleration liberal or
otherwise the right to earn something to
feed themselves the capacity to enjoy
physical security and the right to be
there the right to stay and those issues
I meant to suggest both implicitly and
explicitly have been familiar in Europe
not just since early modern Europe but
well back into
medieval Europe so I would hope that as
we talk about what you described as a
postmodern global world we remember that
this world as post-modernism teaches us
is heterogeneous complex and
multi-layered and an integral part of
that layering remains the set of
questions about states and people's if
you would go to one of the microphones
if you have a question yes but the
microphone in either I'll yes there's a
microphone in the aisle right behind you
IRA I submit that without intolerance
they would no longer be Jews dear Walter
that's the question I yes that's my this
is my submission that's is your answer
it yes and no
the he my my my good friend Walter ever
stop whom I've known for some time has
the great habit of combining pithy pneus
with imposing questions impossible to
answer and as I once worked at the
university of chicago i'm tempted to
answer him what was said to be the
Socratic method at the university of
chicago namely pose an interesting
question and promptly go on leave if um
I i was once you'll be pleased to know
in your a very good company i was once
asked by His Holiness Pope John Paul how
I understood the fact that Jewish memory
persisted despite dispersion and with
that moment of Honor I I said to him
that I thought the beginning of the
answer lay with the fact that Jews did
not and do not have a pope and and
there is um something we'll have heard
the word hutzpah uh-huh the UM and he
was weak it's a privilege to have that
conversation and the what I said was
that because of the absence of
centralized Authority and hierarchy
Jewish communities we're free to develop
with uncommon with astonishing
heterogeneity I believe that the answer
to your question lies in the field of
tension formed on the one side by not
always persistent oppression but by
episodic oppression and on the other
side by the capacity to adapt to local
environments and manage that adaptation
in a remarkably heterogeneous way them
on that last second aspect i will now
recommend my favorite novel of the past
that I've read in the last decade it's
by the Israeli novelist a bee yehohshua
whose precise title is something like
toward the Millennium I may have that
wrong is that correct journey to the end
of the millennium Thank You her and the
that great novel is a story about three
boundaries up in part between the story
men and women this is a man with two
wives traveling in a ship from North
Africa where he is a business person and
is traveling to Spain and France and
Germany but it's also a trip that
reveals boundaries the character of the
boundary between Jews and Christians
which is the subject of your question
really and it also was about the deep
divergence between North African jewelry
of which this person in the year 999
came from where he came and
the world of French and German
ashkenazic jewelry which seemed to him
so terribly strange but those Jewish
communities reproduce themselves in that
diversity and through that diversity
albeit with episodes of punctuated
persecution it since we're flying over
England perhaps the useful place to be
on my question which is uh what how
society to respond when the group that
is poorly tolerated is in itself also a
liberal and intolerant such as radical
Islam so many easy questions they i
would start just with a cautionary word
irrespective of whatever group whatever
religion or whatever nationality
whatever culture one discusses we have
to not be too quick to treat it as a
unity or as unitary cultures we learn I
learned from colleagues and anthropology
colleagues and study comparative
literature colleagues and cultures are
remarkably multi-layered and
heterogeneous that's just an observation
but I think we forget that often say in
works like the late samuel Huntington's
clash of civilizations or his more
recent book on on the what he believed
to be the ability or incapacity of
spanish-speaking newcomers in the united
states to be integrated within the
American fabric these are far too simple
views but the question stands as a good
one
the question irrespective of what
population we're talking about not
everyone practices or even thinks one
should practice toleration in the sense
that I defined it now in my usage I was
primarily perhaps even exclusively
referring to toleration by those who
possess means of repression that is
political and ecclesiastical authorities
and your question was as much or more
about attitudes than it was about
capacity to do something about those
attitudes I don't have a full answer to
the question but whenever I'm in doubt
about that issue I do go back at least
in recent years to John roses volume
political liberalism in which he
dramatically shifted ground from saying
that a liberal society must be grounded
in a common set of doctrines shared by
all in the population to a view that
gave much more space to diversity and
heterogeneity to pluralist but he
insisted on two criteria for what he
called reasonable pluralism and this is
much debated and those criteria were
first that the group irrespective of its
commitments or members of the group or
groups irrespective of their call them
cultural and moral and ethical
commitments when they enter the liberal
public sphere must do so prepared to
deliberate and to deliberate based on
criteria of reason now that's
complicated because what is reason who
judges reason what's the relationship
between regions reason and deep cultural
commitments is there only one kind of
reason actually Rawls was relaxed about
those questions but what he wasn't
relaxed about was the need for what he
called an overlapping consensus as you
know
a superimposition of partial views to
construct the public space where all can
live with each other in relative peace
and that's a vision i think worth
fighting for and that's a vision which
says police protection the right to make
a living the right to be present and the
right to be a full Civic member are
actually rights and not provisional
outcomes but it's a not a simple matter
and conflict is assured so I think one
last question and before you start I
want to invite everyone when we're done
to a reception in the Faculty room which
is directly behind me yes my name is
Logan slow burning I'm a master shooting
the financial engineering here at
Columbia and could you perhaps reflect a
bit on the fallout of the possible
fallout of the Madoff case on the Jewish
community I have nothing original to say
I had questions I don't honestly mr.
Madoff I can't say it appears that he's
a crook he's pleaded guilty for being a
crook on a very large scale he will
likely spend many years in prison as he
should but I think the only way in which
the madoff case enters into the question
of the group is that he made his money
by a view abusing trust that comes from
within trusted networks but it's not to
me Jermaine irrelevant honestly that
this is a Jewish group he could have
been a member of church community or of
a regional community or of an
Occupational community or of a country
club community as he was what mattered
here was that he exploited his networks
exploited and lied to those in his
network artfully brilliantly but
ultimately with consummate stupidity
because he's going to pay the price
thank you thank you very much all right
thank you all for coming
you